trying to get this win y'all trying to
get this win all right I'm going for the
solo black ops trying to get this win so
sup y'all Griffin come on oh let's get
the swing I have never I have gotten
apex wins but I have not gotten any
blackout wins gel want to play hockey I
don't want to play hot pursuit
let's see let's see what happens shout
out what's up syracuse funny bone wait
can you play by yourself fill squat no I
don't want to fill squad ah there you go
so I could you just how can we play hot
pursuit by myself
hot pursuit concerned
I'm trying to keep this way in I know I
should do solo but let me just try this
hot pursuit solo I got this my warm up
match we will get a warm-up match and
then we're gonna let see if we can get
this win
I miss you smash that like button that
subscribe button right here that little
ATC is actually right no it's right here
see it right there
that's the ATC button I'm like somewhere
around here you know I mean that's the
ATC button they were just right there
hit a stop chasing me get away all these
- I don't like these - look at these -
get off me
oh you try to get me oh shoot oh shoot
move those to do all right I don't know
where to go
they always hot l said is a free fire
zone
where should I go where should I go
y'all
you know what i'ma head to the damn
let's go to the damn y'all
oh [ __ ] there's a guy right here I don't
think anybody else oh there's a guy over
there at the dam oh [ __ ] you know what
you know what I'm gonna veer off and
head into these buildings right here oh
please God let to be a gun in here
let there be a gun okay I got a gun
how the [ __ ] has already got police cars
I need five five grappling gun give me
this grappling gun smoke screen uh-huh
give me all this [ __ ] no I don't want
that wait do you think that's do you
think those people right near me I was
distinct messed up damn I hate that
supply drop incoming I should do that
man it's so annoying I'm at the start it
over
but for now you just got to deal with it
sorry
Oh should I need an exam rep circle
collapse I'm gonna get to safety
Oh [ __ ] are shooting big time
over here [ __ ] I'm in the circle too
damn oh here's some firing okay look I'm
already in the circle so it's like [ __ ]
these fools right
oh my god this is a nightmare
all right
[ __ ] if anybody's behind me I mean would
be I'm Way in the circle wait am i
playing with somebody else no oh [ __ ]
you know that gunplay over there oh my
god dude further collapse expected
indicated safe zone oh [ __ ] you hear all
that damn it I mean I need a [ __ ] are
they all out here oh my god this is a
night okay you know what let's go
upstairs
we can't go upstairs y'all
wait I wonder if that guns better I
don't even know what's a good gun or not
five six I need some of that dose I mean
is it like elapsed a minute get to
safety
coz my movements and sound messed up
it's not supposed to be what the hell is
going on man I thought I had it fixed
oh well so when I Supply Drop inbound
Supply Drop inbound you know what [ __ ]
this is this is still in the circle
somewhat i'ma head out over here we got
see what's going on y'all - anything
good in here damn dude nothing
45 oh [ __ ]
Oh somebody's already look at that guy
oh I should go kill that [ __ ]
no what am I talking about what am I
talking about you hear me like acting
like imma kill people okay
oh [ __ ] what is this do I need that
yes okay I need to stay on the outskirts
of the circle it's a lofty oh this
[ __ ] worked as a boat over here
oh [ __ ] look at the circles collapsing
is there a boat over here
whoa-whoa-whoa-whoa whoa-whoa-whoa I
further collapse expected travel to
indicate it's safe zone okay we're gonna
go for a little swim y'all don't fly
swim
a Supply Drop inbound start talking [ __ ]
stop poking [ __ ] oh wait I need to go
this way just a long-ass swim huh
damn dude oh Jesus Christ
well you somebody coming in a boat or
something okay can I get up in there
nope oh my god
I'm about the street die because I'm
swimming keep on swimming keep on
swimming
does the circle come in the [ __ ]
circles come in y'all oh my god how far
away am i oh I'm not that far
oh my god I'm far enough though Jesus
come on
come on come on run [ __ ] this dudes
taking forever to run how's your car
over here oh there's no cars oh my god
I'm about to die from the circle y'all
I'm trying to do a couple of solo wins
first before I play with anybody else
[ __ ] [ __ ] is this circle wet
she's so far away can you die from being
tired oh [ __ ] there it is and just past
me god dammit
I'm almost there I'm almost there
brontosaurus indicated safe zone oh I
did it I made it oh [ __ ] he dropped the
thing over there look oh [ __ ]
I don't have any [ __ ] you hear I hear
people oh [ __ ] look where I'm at I'm at
just [ __ ] place oh my god this is
there was a kind of fat guy question
sitrep so collapse I'm gonna get to
safety
shut up need Supply Drop incoming what
is that what is that what kind of ammo
is that 9-millimeter don't need it
oh [ __ ] dude
I just need some armor damn man
I see anybody
and this is a nightmare can I get some
armor in this [ __ ]
how many smoke screens am I gonna find
oh [ __ ] I think people are in there
[ __ ] [ __ ] over there
this is crazy
two dollars from Vancouver thank you hit
that super chat hit that super chat
y'all don't be bashful hit that super
chat oh [ __ ] oh my god
oh [ __ ] look look look listen does it
[ __ ] they don't see me none of these
[ __ ] see me [ __ ] red forest
what did I just shoot I don't know what
I just shot oh [ __ ] oh I was trying to
shoot the smoke
dammit man it's [ __ ] annoying
I know shooting at the car is never a
good idea what number 13 no number 13
y'all for my first time out
I'm not mad at being number 13 all right
add to figure out what the hell's going
on just sound sync man god it's annoying
oh it's working fine yeah pieces of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
all right okay no kills all right you
know what I'm not gonna play hot pursuit
I'm gonna go solo all right here we go
y'all I'm gonna do a stole out we gonna
do last uh hello
yeah I don't know why it's looking like
that it is what it is man
what's up y'all that Dukes I'm using a
[ __ ] you know logy dope I mean
whatever they call this [ __ ] actually
what I should do is change all set could
have changed the settings for YouTube
like to output it better but for right
now this is good just making sure it
lasts so I'm talking [ __ ] griffonstone
oh I'm trying to get this win man I'm
trying to first win oh trying to get on
my own look at this dude
wow it's got a rabbit face I don't know
how people do all that stuff how come I
can find armor by myself but not when
that's annoying
sup y'all what's up we trying to get
this first win
why don't you get help
on this street all right here we go just
black out with
I consider old contacts hostile consider
all contacts our style is already for
this rippen oh man wait wait wait not
gonna drop yet I'm gonna drop and the
drops I can go far away
all right we get it pick up some speed
and then um again we gonna glide son
don't glide does anybody come into my
area oh I don't see anybody come into
this area over here oh yes just somebody
right there oh my god my other somebody
already in that area right there did you
see that oh [ __ ]
just run Griffin Oh somebody's in front
of me oh my god I gotta get a gun
[ __ ] game man [ __ ] close the [ __ ]
there you go sorry gun in here please be
a gun in here
okay you know what it's not that it's
not the ideal gun but I'll take two [ __ ]
I need another here we go here we go
okay here it is yes daddy's daddy's got
one already have one of those okay get
rid of this [ __ ] for this okay here we
go here we go that's good
oh that level - yeah level - yeah [ __ ]
look at me alright
wait where's the oh [ __ ] I'm not even
close to the [ __ ] circle
and it dude I should be running people
could see one in this [ __ ] solo time
let's check the roof see anything here
what is this [ __ ] hole trophy system
let's grab that I don't know what the
[ __ ] it is but okay that's good
30 seconds anything anybody's in here oh
I should come in blastin [ __ ] that right
five six and four backpack yes sitrep
cynical collapse I'm gonna get to safety
stop yelling at me I hate that guy
anything in here nope
alright let's get the [ __ ] out of here
right [ __ ]
wait did you hear that did you stop
acting like people died please chat wait
we get a quick share get a quick share
this on the tube on the twits on the
twits there we go
oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] is all over here man
you know what I gotta use this [ __ ] I'll
come back to some work man grappling gun
is useless Shh quiet quiet quiet
oh [ __ ] this is so oh [ __ ] there's some
mass shooting going on to the right
somebody's got a helicopter already god
damn dude oh there they are
you stay in these trees oh my god behind
me
oh [ __ ] to shooting in front of me right
now oh man oh there's a truck I go get
this truck what you thinking chat car I
got away is delayed see what he's got
oh okay why did it do that how do you
okay what ammo do I need no I need five
six I'll take that
give me just grenade I don't need a
backpack I'm out oh my god I got a kill
y'all see that oh my god I can't believe
it
I never get kills like that
oh I hear a [ __ ] guy on a [ __ ]
thing
oh [ __ ] I gotta go well there's another
guy right there look at that oh [ __ ] oh
my god oh man I waited too long
[ __ ] man damn
let's get that kill cam see what
happened oh I let this guy kill me and
he's behind the thing oh that's terrible
to get this death [ __ ] [ __ ] okay one
more
I know hesitation is a killer we look at
these chats it's not supposed to be any
sync issues man I checked myself just
refresh the stream if you refresh the
stream I think you're gonna be fine
wait let me see man I don't want to stop
it and start it again but yeah shouldn't
be any issues
[Music]
all right here we go Stu this [ __ ] again
I got my one kill though son one kill
son with the lesbian Asian girl this
games been out a while but I still
haven't got a win
I think it's happening for some people
and not others cuz when I check
cuz I'm looking at the stream myself to
check the check and it seems to be fine
you know
Oh [ __ ] my backpack they should let you
keep this stuff that would be dope you
can carry this stuff over to the game
alright y'all
okay so I got do it differently this
time no hesitation and I gotta be
aggressive when I get into the circle we
gotta get to the circle all these in
sales are lying
listen I'm not gonna be mad at any cow
there any super chats don't don't don't
be bashful I know my aim is awful really
you got to tell me that [ __ ]
English is all very soft the Mamas aim
is offered
all right um where should I go you know
what I'm gonna try to get to the boat
okay there you go
okay there we go I'm not gonna make it
to the boat
oh my God look at those two guys at the
barn already look at everybody going
there oh my god that guy's going there
okay I got to go to this house right
here oh I'm gonna die fast guys we got
to hope that there's [ __ ] in this barn
right here wait wait wait wait we get to
the top side of this barn
I'll give me a gun give me a gun baby
yes let's go two guns I don't want a
shotgun oh okay here we go got these
guns in here was this e55 but it is 9
millimeter by millimeter [ __ ] us a
firing on each other already where's the
circle till collapse detected advisory
location 2 indicates it's safe zone oh
[ __ ] I should pick this up huh yeah give
me this [ __ ]
5 6 got any 5 6 of 50 Cal oh my god here
we go again where I'm far away from the
[ __ ] circle oh [ __ ] come on Oh
censored art I picked that up huh
oh these [ __ ] are firing over
here dude I got to get to the circle I
can't be [ __ ] around we got to get to
the circle I'm not beating here I've
been in here oh [ __ ] he's mother for
this just dudes over here I need some
[ __ ] oh my god I love jumping out the
window by the way it's my favorite [ __ ]
look I see somebody Oh No all right here
we go here we go I'm going through these
cornfields
okay here we go here we go
why did I jump on the roof oh [ __ ] I
hear somebody
well somebody already went through here
sit Rep Circle collapse I'm gonna get to
safety
oh this is a [ __ ] gun oh my god dude
I don't want this guy swordfish okay we
gonna run through the [ __ ] check me
out
being all stealth and [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] they'll swim across and we're
off to see the Wizard [ __ ] about to
drown oh [ __ ] oh my gosh unless you got
a dick in her mouth
Oh oh [ __ ] [ __ ] was that well there's a
truck right here I'm a house just trucks
there's a gray just [ __ ] place Oh
somebody's already been in here
oh [ __ ] y'all close this door what is
this [ __ ] for [ __ ] eat a paint can
for
oh that's a sneaky way to go to this
other room cases somebody in here
already
check me out oh my god
we gotta get to kill cam on this one oh
oh this one [ __ ] in the room already
I didn't see his ass man [ __ ] man all
that and you die this was so [ __ ]
annoying about this game
all right this is just as like this is
nonsense y'all
[Music]
damnit alright one more game actually
have a show I got to get to 114
yeah I think I'm streaming at a low
stream thing I got to make this higher
that's what I got to do I know I did
find some guns fast at round all right
let me look at the chat and see what
y'all have to say all right um I tried
on that one I was straight [ __ ] you
need a win guys I don't need you to tell
me that I suck okay I know
alright so saying that is you just be an
[ __ ] so how about we have some
constructive criticism in here of things
to do
I'm fine go into the water I didn't know
you could do that she's in the water too
long she sound like she's like I said
noise we all want to hear like yeah that
means we give it its all let me see if
somebody no they're not on yet oh here
we go
this is the one y'all who's shooting at
me from across the way damn I just got
to get to a building get some guns and
then swoop to the circle right away
unless I'm not in the circle you know I
mean that's the strategy this is gonna
be the one shut up god yeah yeah some
rude on unsupportive [ __ ] man
I need some support stream support
training times over
I'm dropping right away [ __ ] this one
one establish on drop zone
I should type Hawk is live
I'm going right to the [ __ ] damn
let's go to the damn y'all right
all right here's this just this room in
the damn let's go let's go let's go
let's go come on y'all
is this a door oh my god
here we go okay give me a gun yes ah I
need a gun and yes I need another gun
all right all right
okay I'll keep the shotgun oh [ __ ]
I'm gonna hurt myself with that [ __ ] god
damn it dude
oh I don't have any [ __ ] here we go
here we go sitrep
potential collapse detected relocation
indicated safe zone is advised
what is this five six
Barney dis I need this I need this oh my
god I'm not in the circle y'all god damn
it
Oh give me that give me that give me
that I don't know what the [ __ ] that is
what is this barricade I don't want to
[ __ ] barricade
trauma kit I will take that armor plate
not that Molotov I need some five six
how far away am i oh I'm so far
god damn it what is this [ __ ] I don't
know what the [ __ ] that is I come in
here blastin will get my shotgun I don't
want that okay we gotta go huh damn it
we gotta go Supply Drop inbound okay
here we go
[ __ ] it we gotta go
sit Rep Circle collapse imminent get to
safety would you speak with chat will
you be supportive [ __ ] guys a [ __ ] I'm
gonna get this first win I swear to God
oh [ __ ] I gotta go [ __ ] oh man I just
realized the time so you guys got me out
here [ __ ] around I'm missing shows I
got to go oh oh this little buggy thing
right there man I'm gonna I'm not even
gonna be able to finish this game I
don't even need that animal I just got
just give me a [ __ ] Armor and [ __ ]
there's a [ __ ] right there
oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] ran me over
oh we gotta see this killcam I got to go
anyway but that was look at this dude
okay I'm here oh my god oh wow I don't
even know I did that oh that's that guy
check him out
oh my alright guys thanks for watching
I'll be on later
I appreciate you and I'm out Griffin